okay so mmm hi everyone sorry to keep
you waiting
I think just nice some other guys just
just streamed in as well thanks so much
for coming for talk this talk really is
going to guide you to you know a little
bit about web accessibility what it is
how you can get started you need zero
experience coming in here to learn about
it so just to introduce the team a
little bit they're the five of us that
started this web and mobile
accessibility initiative in Singapore
because we identified that web and
mobile accessibility was very lacking
not just in Singapore but I think in the
region and we needed to do something
about it so the fire of us put put
together to essentially learn more about
web accessibility from young and Dixon
the first two on the left so they are
both people have visual impairments so
as users but they also developers so
they've been you know interfacing with
web and mobile accessibility the entire
lives so they teach us a lot about it so
I think over the past four to five
months we've actually come up with some
sort of a curriculum as to which we can
invite more deaths to kind of learn
about web accessibility you know be on a
fortnightly basis or whatsoever
you know looking at the different steps
on how as a collective those that wanna
join us can go out to the different
regional companies with their websites
and mobile apps to make them accessible
so the agenda for today's workshop
released in three parts the first part
is just me nagging a little bit so this
the power you can doze off and then
section 2 will be the users perspective
how a person is a visual impairment kind
of interfaces with a website and then we
also do a screen reader walk through web
step by step we will go to a website
together we've asked you
and then we'll we will also give you a
challenge later where you have to blank
out your screen so you can't see your
screen at all and then interface as
though you were someone who's blind to
fight we see some information on our
website so then section three will talk
about developers perspective what do you
actually need to do if you're if you're
a practicing web accessibility in order
to reach a high standard of web
accessibility law so essentially the
focus for us for this session
I think it's focused more towards web
accessibility and less towards mobile
accessibility I think because of the
nature of the conference but also for us
a lot of the information that is you
know on the internet is still on
websites and a lot of the information
that is necessary for daily living think
of banking think of transportation
travel if they are not accessible then
people vision impairment cannot access
those services in an issue everything is
you know being digitized and going oh -
oh yeah so the first part what really is
a 1:1 why
so we use this term quite a lot a 1:1
why and why is it important so
essentially a11y is a numeral name for
accessibility so the reason why they
came up with such a term was because
blind people used to it as well they
want to feel everything 140 characters
so that's why they they came up with
this little shortcut as well right and
why is the important is because I think
traditionally about 70% of the
information that we process as humans is
true site right if if you kind of
reflect on the last 30 different
websites they've you've interfaced you
could have done it without any sound
right
we're just visuals you're able to
interface to the website really well but
what happens if you know you can hear it
but you can't see think of maybe the top
three websites that you visit on a daily
basis how you interface with them what
kind of structures do they have that's
what I think people vision primal face
and this is not so much a a point to me
you feel like a bit sad that you know
they don't have access or whatsoever but
to show you that there's actually a
different way a more a refreshing tick
on how you can kind of you know assess
the structure of your website or
different websites that might even
improve the way you look at things in
the products that you build up okay so
just a little bit of a background here
on how people with vision impairment or
those who are blind use computers there
are two main ways the one on the right
is I can't really capture the audio but
he's using a screen reader so what a
screen reader is is everything that is
displayed on your screen you can
actually hear it out so it's that's how
is it's a it works right and you know
now I think we're also transitioning
into a phase way because we have a lot
to do with voice UI so we definitely can
interface with you know the Internet in
many different ways but on the Left we
still have what we call a refreshable
Braille display
so they take line by line of text that
you get on websites or what documents or
whatsoever and it processes it to you
know display little dots that are
Braille and the reason why they would
still use Braille in this day and age
and not just everything show audio is
because they want to look towards having
good grammar and punctuation something
that you know audio just can't do at a
moment so that's the currently the two
is that people have visual impairment
interferes what I like to say about Brio
is it's like how my mom forced me to
learn Chinese even though I don't want
to so parents who are blind or have
blankets or so the one that kids to
learn Braille you
cause it helps them with their education
on the aspect as well yeah so the next
question is who does accessibility right
in one run why so I think on a global
scale if we look towards the west they
have been a lot of developments in you
know the past decades one example give
us in the EU this was fairly recent
early last year the EU had a legislative
legislative mandate to say okay all the
websites of governmental services need
to be web accessible and after that
essentially they said since I was a
great success let's make all the mobile
apps of governmental services web
accessible sorry mobile accessible right
so the EU is working towards that in the
US it's also a very interesting case
whereby for the past 27 years they have
this thing called American Disability
Act and what happens is if you are a
person with a disability and a
particular company you know it's not
accessible to you you can actually plan
up a lawyer to sue the company and they
can't come to sue they have to comply so
this one example about three three
months ago is it what's the date day I
can see October yeah
so people with visual impairment
actually used to match calm because they
say that we want to find love as well so
we value your service and we want it to
be made accessible right so this is the
story also of how when we've spoken to
you know places like a B&B and the rest
they start their accessibility journey
because they get sued
so they actually also is a global
community of web accessibility experts
mainly other accessibility engineers
from all the large tech companies you
can think of all there and when I joined
this I think one of the the things that
really stood up for me was I shall
define other people in Southeast Asia
they were on this chat and I couldn't
find anyone right
I saw a private slide shadow a11y - sta
and I thought you were Southeast Asia by
it was Seattle right so there really was
no one for watchin so I mean John back
to this point first so to talk about
ASEAN I think the examples I gave you of
the EU and in the u.s. those were
essentially legislative mandates the
government has enforced it down and I
don't think we expect to see that
happening in Southeast Asia in the next
10 years because we are very
pro-business maybe in places like I
think Korea and Japan are starting to at
the moment to have a little bit more
legislative mandates so the the
responsibility lies with the community
to ensure that there is web
accessibility so then I think that's
this there's a stronger community aspect
of this if we want to do this together
for the ASEAN region so the question is
you know you guys probably work in
different companies of different you
know products rd you know web web
accessible and what does it take to
actually make your web accessible right
so a very very short answer will dive
deeper later is that it's not very much
different from your daily grind it does
not take a lot of extra effort for you
to to be web accessible sorry so one of
the main things is just you know you
need proper labeling indexing of all the
different web elements that you have on
your product and you know to constantly
review
if a screen reader that's what we call a
manual scanning now that's also
automated scanner also to check for
accessibility
so that's on a user needs basis and then
there's actually a global standard for
web accessibility as well they will look
to us for compliance so normally we try
meet both of those so you know one of
the the first steps in which we would
try and help a company to become web
accessible which we are currently doing
so we go to two different companies and
every audit there are their websites and
say hey you're not accessible do you
want do something about it mmm so it's
very fun for us it's like you know
companies that we interface with daily
knowing that we can do something about
it so we were audit by using a screen
reader and I think it's really fun when
use of screen reader because it's all
about being a keyboard shortcut Pro
because you can't use a mouse because
people a vision impairment cannot see
the cursor right so everything is you
see later when when takes and demos it's
it's super fast you know the way he goes
through it and I think it's refreshing
that you get to view the structure of
your website with a different sense
canet bring about the new form of
innovation in a way you see things
that there might be interesting to
explore mmm so yeah so I think I'm
reaching the last few parts for my my
aspect but I wanted to share a little
bit about you know these abilities are
shy and a11y initiative so these
abilities is a company that I started
it's a social impact startup that
marries disability designing technology
and we essentially a social enterprise
and and you know with this initiative
what we're doing is we're saying can we
get more developers who are keen to
learn about web and mobile accessibility
to learn from young and Nixon about
those aspects and then together as a
group we'll go out and either you don't
make your company's products more
accessible first take it back to your
own companies and at the same time
together we would you know venture out
and help other companies as well so
that's really what we
I'll be doing and essentially like like
I mentioned because action is
pro-business we can't expect the
government to come up with anything like
that to ensure access to the Internet
which is considered basic human right in
some cases if it's not web accessible
then people visual impairment don't have
access to the Internet so we would have
to be the enforcers of this new web
standard action yeah so the stages of
web accessibility at the moment really
briefly is you know to do an audience
and then we fix the box and then the
last step is to have make sure that we
comply with the global standards
sometimes the global standards there are
a lot of things that we can do it out
but it just gives you that the stamp of
approval I guess and it really covers
not just people with vision impairment
but a wider range you find it very
interesting how people who are deaf or
hard of hearing or people who are
severely paralyzed interface of the
internet and this guidelines cover that
as well
so how can you start like I mentioned
you can take this back to your own
company to practice whatever simple
things you learn I think at the very
most by the end of this workshop you
would have learned how to use screen
readers quite a bit so try and use
screen readers on the products that that
you felt built so far and and see how
accessible this and then at the same
time if you choose to join us on for
meetups for for the Asha and a 1-1 Y
initiative then we will go to other
companies with better web and mobile
accessibility and help them out so the
next step is I think we're gonna have
Dickson to demo a little bit how he
actually uses the screen reader to
interface with websites and from a user
standpoint and inkyung I think he also
demo a little bit on how he uses a text
editor or while using Eclipse so he will
use Eclipse IDE to essentially show you
how use a screen reader to do that
I didn't reduce them well enough but
Young is grabs for
blank order Dixon is any rescue of
Computing's first visually impaired
student so they've definitely had to
jump through a lot of Hoops in terms of
how their colleagues or schoolmates
collaborate so that they can you know be
at the same level so that's definitely
very interesting the the last two points
I want to mention is because we're in a
very very small group so let's keep it
very informal if you can't follow
something or you have a burning question
just raise your hand voice it out and
then we will address it because I think
there's something that potentially would
be very new to everyone let me just have
a show of hands who is looking at web
accessibility for the first time okay
most I said one two okay so therefore I
think any questions that you have
someone else might have as well so don't
feel shy to just voice up in the the
next time so I think we want to have a
to check so you should have a your
headphones with you I think we'll use
the Safari browser and there will be an
info sheet with a bit of keyboard
shortcuts as well do you have that on
your to the ready okay so this is
distance Twitter account he will post
your pin a post with the download link
to this info sheet and yeah okay so just
give us a minute for the extent to kind
of post this on Twitter just before the
actual session so soon
so now is your day moving on jacquard we
shop at first
okay okay is the Bluetooth setup really
okay guys so you just give us a few
minutes we set up you can hear
yeah and okay just duplicator okay okay
yeah okay
so now can learn this begin okay
Amazon and buy all day to me to drink is
a visit I smoked it was a dialog and so
it's actually the speech view or because
I measure you cannot get on you so I
think you can see what right so hi
everyone so over here I am currently
running a screen reader which is self
talking and so now what I'm gonna soft
show you guys is how I would sort of go
about using Amazon as well as a local we
a local retailer to sort of get
information about buying a specific
product and nvo you know compare and
contrast the differences between these
two websites so right now what I'll do
is to press the it's a standard or D
shortcut
since I'm on Windows to go to to
amazon.com and see if this loads ah okay
over here okay so over here I I know
that the page has finished loading
because it's it started talking and
reading out you know the title and and
so forth so right now let's say that I
wanted to buy I actually do what if you
do on the game buy a new laptop so let's
see if I can find the end the search bar
on this page so over here
one thing that screen readers provide is
are actually very like efficient and
fast ways of finding various structural
elements of your page so right now I'm
going to move to the next or edit field
and navigation network network so so it
said a bunch of things that this is it
this is all part part of of the banner
of the page and now I am on this search
field and I can start typing so so let's
say that I I was buying this particular
machine so one thing about screen
readers is that they are used this is
this is this is synthesized speech so it
so it always pronounces the same words
or sentences or phrases in exactly the
same way so it sort of becomes possible
to get used to how it speaks and then so
you can slowly like increase the speech
rate so this is like typically how I use
this page so right now I'm going to try
to do is to I so I I could start off by
just pressing the arrow keys to you know
slowly sequentially read through the
entire page so this is roughly what it
sounds like
so as I you know move down you can hear
that I'm moving you you you can see that
I'm moving past the search field and
then after that this is this is
basically the neck the sign in via the
pages and stuff so let's say that I
didn't want to do this because this
would take me a long time so what I will
now try to do is to move to the first
level one heading so we soft rely a lot
on on having correct structural amounts
on this page so it's it main landmarks
search results so I know that this is
exactly where I want to be and I can
move so so was quite a fan above result
so I I can sort of move to the next
heading
so here let's say that I wanted to you
know buy this computer but you know so
it it's it it's it a bunch of things
like the processor speed the hard drive
size capacity Rev and so off so I can
also move more slowly work by what
instead of only relying on it reading
the entire line or peg or paragraph at a
time yeah so this is you know the screen
and it's anything there and so forth
so let's say that I've wanted to go to
come to this page so I've just okay and
so it has finished loading and again one
girl what I'm gonna try to do is that
since the main content of the page was
after in level one hitting I'm going to
try this again to to to CV box yup so
I'm here and and so it told me that so
it told me that five point five stars
Wow okay with for customer reviews so
over here like this is all what it it
says and I can continue to move down and
so you know the list price is the price
and so forth so I can so this list it it
told me that I am entering this list and
I can sort continue to move down and so
forth and what I can also do is that you
know this move since moving by hitting
worked for me earlier so I'm gonna try
it again because now I'm makings of a an
educated guess out there the other major
sections of the webpage are also
preceded by hitting so I'm gonna try
that
oops yup so now I'm I'm in a level 2
heading so this is a the frequently
bought special offers have a question so
forth yup and so the technical details
and so forth are heading level 1 so I I
can move to the next or previous heading
or I can also move to a specific level
heading so you know it's of depends on
what I know this page has so this is you
know roughly like how I would use I
would navigate web page so like you know
up to this point you know do any of you
guys have any questions
holiday tea for you to like be able to
everything yes I started using this in
like 2004 so I have to come backwards
yeah tough 13 Oh 13 years yeah so I mean
you know so like it's like as you stuck
I think I started around you know the
way that it was earlier than you as you
become more used to how it says certain
things and then you just slowly increase
it by a few percent every you know a few
victor or something like because ii
imagine with me using the computer at
that we you know so it's like you you
basically just spending your time
waiting for it to tell you things rather
than you know you doing your your own
thing hmm yeah so it is possible to get
used mmm any more questions so right so
if not you know I will Nix compare the
experience on you know Amazon versus a
local retailer how do you so I can or
how how do you spell it
thanks dot sg3
well why is it taking so long to Lord oh
yeah I remain a trifle so yes I know
yeah it's okay thanks it's yeah so over
here it's you know it's not sort of
notice that it's also telling me exactly
the characters that I selected and so
far so so that I know that ah yes okay
so now we are you know we are here so on
this page I'm gonna try the same trick
again because I want to move there first
you know and add edit field on this page
and I can I can do so
oops oh okay so it seems that there is a
some Moodle dollar dialog so this is
totally unscripted because the previous
time that was here this thing didn't
exist so let's see wait what why what
with what the hell okay whatever yeah
okay okay I mean that has to be
something for you know for par on the
path of the developers but anyway okay
so the meanders party so I'm I've just
did the same thing that I tried so I am
now in the search field and I can start
typing again
and okay and so I'm here so now let me
repeat the same X you know navigations
off method so I'm gonna try to move the
next hitting that I find so you know
like I mean I I haven't gone through all
all the headings of this page but just
by the the headings that I see this is
probably not gonna get me anywhere
quickly so the next thing I'm gonna try
is to go back up to the top of the page
and so besides headings that I I guess
that you guys would be would have you
know have heard of there is of another
way of dividing the structure of your
web page so these soft and this is
called a region so you you can think of
a region as a way of expressing in the
HTML what you guys must perceive
visually on the page you know so for
example if the page has a bunch of
navigation links at the top you know
going across the top then you were
actually um and close that in HTML you
know in a banner in a path and closing
you know less banner greater tags so
this is how a you know someone who is
using some other interface can also
perceive this page so let me try to see
if this works to see if they have
divided their page into regions right
sorry that's that's all this okay so
it's it navigation Lima okay I mean so I
guess this is where the they are the
site navigation stuff is and then oh
okay so there are no more landmarks so
okay so these two are the real huge
states that I often try to quickly get
past the page you know past the
irrelevant stuff to the main content of
the page so I guess you you you can
think of it as the equivalent of skim
reading or just you know your eyes
moving to where the main parts of the
page is so now I have no choice I have
to you know explore this page more that
most
thought thoroughly from the top and I'm
going to start reading all right so why
hurt so I noticed that over here after
the after dr such after the search view
right so after the search view there's
actually this thing that says such
results and then I know that so there
are a lot of hits and I've okay so this
is this appears to be a way for me to
select what I want to solve so let's see
what this reads are e okay I mean I've
known about this stuff so I'm just going
to escape and and hope that this didn't
do anything right so yeah so I'm so so
so now I know that so so this appears to
be the first actual hit that this is the
Dell XPS 13 so what I sort of learned
from soft light this is that I can also
move to the next or previous combo box
which is what the soft HTML this
particular element is caught on the page
so I know that in the future I can from
the top of this page I can basically
move to the next combo box and then you
just below that is the main content of
the page but you know the point that I'm
so drunk that guy you know do the point
I'm trying to illustrate is that since
you know the first tool like method sort
of fail then I have to work a bit harder
to find where the main content of the
page is and although I know now that the
contents or does all these search
results are actually right after this
combo box where you are supposed to be
able to select how you saw the results
that this is site-specific you know so
one thing isn't a site specific and the
other is that this is bound to change
when perhaps the visual layer of the
page changes yeah so let me just go to
the first
our bazaar for the XPS 13 and Sivir I
can read the the specifications for this
particular computer so the pitch has
again finished loading oh okay so now I
just tried to see if I can move by
hitting any work so now I'm I'm here so
so so this is how this is it
reading you know the details of this
page okay so you know this like
hopefully this or gives you an idea you
know of like the difference you know of
having you know good structural elements
in your in you know your webpage versus
not having the structural elements you
know so like like if I'm actually gonna
buy an XPS 13 I guess you guys would
know recite over he preferred to buy
from so any questions up to this point
yeah professional
always so it depends on the on how the
website was done so in the previous what
the previous example for Amazon what I
was able to do is to actually so in this
page I didn't really have to do any
site-specific workarounds because moving
by hitting sort of books so headings are
sort of sort of you know thing is
defined in the HTML specification as a
way for you to logically divided content
and to use you know like levels like
level one could be the read you know the
actual title and so forth and then level
two would be sub headings or subsections
and so forth so one is that on Amazon I
didn't have to you know like spend extra
you know brain brain cell cycles to
understand you know the layout of this
page and you know and so hopefully you
know that like answers your question
like if you're the website you know has
this like standard width or standard
ways of navigation then no we need those
specific workarounds would be necessary
hmm yep so like doing a single page
application so that's that's gonna be
sort of I'll cut a bit on that later on
in sort of the little examples but soft
like the day see that there's a widow
actually mark parts of your page as
being so called a live region so so
you're saying that this page has this
part of your of the page has something
that can change so you can have elements
add or remove from the Dom you know in
this particular section and then if
you're if a particular interface that
you are using to access the site
understands this mock-up which is creamy
deliciousness then it's able to be
automatically announced changes to the
specific part of the page only yeah so
you do have a fan of L the value of
control over that
yeah so I'll be talking in a you know
data in a data section so also one
finals of thing about how I you know use
headings and regions to move about this
page I can also move by region here on
Amazon yup so I know here that don't
there's such a place I can search and
it's the mean content so the other thing
is that a three-meter isn't the only
thing that is gonna be there's going to
benefit from your site being you know
structure e having good structural
markup so you know I guess that some of
you would have used some resource like
Instapaper or readability or you know
that your browser's really more to
extract the main parts of the page you
know the articles we talked without the
distraction of the sighs you know links
and have this one site so forth so I bet
that part of how it does this is
actually relying on good structural your
your site being structurally easy to
analyze by a computer program
mm you know so like having this mock-up
not only you know it interrupt me
benefit more more you know people then
you think it does so so you know
[Music]
okay guys sadly you stand up if I said
all days I understand a bit so can you
hear at the back can you guys hear me
clearly okay alright so uh you guys is
accelerated into the very high speed so
good a little bit so a lot of people
will like ask me some questions like how
can I go to do programming how can they
run a program what is my difficulties so
now I just give you guys a brief
demonstration to see how can you do it
using screen readers
so um usually everybody use a mouse but
for me I just keep our only everywhere
everything is based on a shortcut so
here I'm using Eclipse to write some
Java code lower the bond package like
they love it let them look there so here
for example if you want to create a new
class right it's mostly space limit
values what they're doing videos
application context meant so in July so
to open this menu usually of you you
guys will press right arrow right but
for Piero press application so if
instead of writing mouse click I use
application so here you can see that
screen reader we support line user body
gives them a lot of information so from
here you can make any other possible use
organic don't you Oh plus XI plus W this
is the shortcut so after them then the
menu if you show me the new something
new something new I will press right
arrow to open a new insight project a
classic that will be classy name calling
it y de ello CSS never cancel button
leaving them blank blank blank race
never ever ever get talked into this
okay so like what usually
they want to read something I just
simply read from top to bottom
how about leg for the class my plank ok
first you know tell Artie Lange leg leg
leg leg leg simplest public key lamb
save me Oh
each maybe father he look like the snake
left whatever he pleased and it look
less st t tea party trailer stays a
equals thing does nice hey let's create
left right there semicolon
okay so if i write something like this
so usually you will ask me okay how can
i know that there is some error there's
a typo error orgasm same things that
error or even unlike for example I
forgot import my library or something so
I am using the different screen reader
from exams and using just this one is
using NVDA so for Charles you can write
some script to support this community so
there's the built-in script
that man will tell me like for example
in some some in some part of the code
because some error it will show
like I think the red color right so it
will tell me that this this part is
invalid so lower leg plot the class
might never clash leg brace this one is
finite black publicly bring luck there
right there tamela's with Nicolas
invalid least it's been the listen world
here evening and we have some
probabilities oh the values I so let's
see what happen so here I I guess I can
also a specially made necessary evils
menu file menu to move through items
with almost evil then the move
provides results out there of your
controlling the 2012 control Eagles
mostly menu menu file menu to vote to
Lyons press up or down arrow period at
limit men who said I would text
curiously control the default control
your equals let's go through people's is
it big race
right great
sorry where's the problem with the
little speaker
okay
now we combine again how often I you
know and find the error and and then
find find out how to solve this error
control one again this is also a
shortcut for the pastoralism absolutely
live parrot java camera so you can see
that it will rig me reason we like in
import ' ELISA ' because now and you
writing codes I need to know every bump
situation measurements parenthesis the
ID
it was able to raise my brain up there
Mike there's any cool and as he did so
another thing is how can I use that code
completion so usually when you type
right you can see the list of suggestion
for me again I have to press like
shortcut to move to this for example
periods you show me a list of available
function so I just simply press that to
beneath them so I'm going to use the up
and down arrow to find it to do it
please
one that will never ever see deep deep
deep he says stay home say that by his
heat right guys de lettres her s monkey
teeth as indeed he left Paris to go
bigger so when public questioning blank
public staff robbery like to call my
class why
e o controlspace my demo class and space
variables so that interface level
control space when I don't like left and
right there or like right there a clam
pepper my demo question when when ii ii
o period and wait let them wait look
wait look wait wait the street wait look
there right there plan semicolon control
and now away from control dec 11 and
we're stuck yeah again this is another
situation that will show me the error so
now for example I have a big project I
don't know where where the Airways I'm
gonna open all the glasses to see the
invalid nice I just again use all my
shortcut to see this the menu of the
error I'll check in with see cybertek
this game state this game function cube
X 3 new the level 0 arrows arrows left
at level 1 invalid character constant
reason and entered his game and it
selected Lisbon and left there the
apostrophe s the faster we get the
transnational quote left barren quote
quote invalid I didn't in our tea and
sent right back
' right there ' Shiva quote and infamous
quote list on and left a request read
one quote right there
control s and close my demo and it will
instead plan man when Sonny
control control that $11 and see my note
and then string one when okay so from
this you can see the way how can
- coding how can I deal with like
problem how to I can't I can recognize
the red line of era or anything's the
final thing is how can I debug the
answer is right right now it's almost
impossible so for example I want to know
how the codes were I just simply I want
to see how the prints function work
really I just simply go to this function
and the press f3
okay so do you have any question
yeah so how do detects in this yeah I
can detect syntax error by like for
example when I worked there and we try
to make an error now we've got a clerk
and so he called me at a semicolon
okay so we're if I go through this line
we start we start at left arrow
straighten both record tell me this this
one this one is in invalid with that
left arrow straight through cable is
like very invalid right parent is mean
this right presence yeah we got some
problem there so I can guess that I
never miss the semicolon semicolon and
right with police target left Perico
streets and code right there is any
colon and then it will not read invalid
anymore so that is all I can detect
leaks obvious syntax error but this one
only working for my screen reader is
mcjones if you use me Nvidia if we have
to run and after running fell I can open
the arrow real viewer and then try to
find the errors it's very visible we are
of course
yeah Happy's like different in different
IDs on things other things that you'd
like you wish the IDS this better in
general or just general like what you're
like things really frustrate them for
example Eclipse is very good visual like
Microsoft Visual Studio is also good I
mean it's a bit heavy but it is still
fine I can I can code I can things that
I use stss Springs those as sweet is the
website the other thing to building
website which is spring from work is
also what we do Nina but now I'm using
Android studio to work in and one dress
you know I have some problem with
configuration I cannot change something
and setting and sometimes it's when
whenever I want screen reader is going
to be slower than then no more yeah yeah
so I think the next part when we're
going to walk through the screen reader
process right mm I think the key thing
to note for you is the concept of what
you see is right here make sure
everything that you see they're looking
for as you go to the your visual flow
can match up with the audio flow that
you're listening to I think that's the
most important thing to emphasize as
you're as you're going to era so yeah so
there's a cheesy here and I think with
the white used what you see is why you
here we're gonna demo with a different
kind of e-commerce site we're going to
go to so already as in its own hangar so
so if you want you can just wear one
side it is possible so you can hear the
instructions as well hmm
that's not me honey do but if you find
it too difficult then disprove or sighs
laughs right this is what Eugene what
content you visit okay so the first
thing is you know that you guys will
want to be to be do is to turn on
voiceover itself and so the key the key
stroke for that is command + f5 so this
is this is a toggle that turns it on and
off and you and this works in any
application so the other thing is that
voiceover in its default configuration
if this is the first time that you guys
switch it on okay if this is the first
time that you guys have it on then you
might have this dialogue that asks you
if you want to if you want to take part
in this a QuickStart tutorial so few
feet or you just use your mouse to or
okay pal keyboard to cancel that first
or I believe you you you can press as
Cape so it's so once you know voiceover
is on the other setting change that
might be very helpful is to modify a
particular Safari setting as a list and
some other sort of pretty important
things is that voiceover its default
configuration is also extremely verbose
so it is sort of trying to be helpful by
telling you what are the keys that you
are able to press but what black bar the
keys you are able to press when you're
when your focus is on a particular place
so if you find that tool you know if you
need to stop it from speaking just press
the control key and another key that is
very that would be very helpful for your
exploration of learning on voiceover is
using its keyboard help come on
so on that pitch I said that a lot of
commands use something called a
voiceover key and I said on this page
that you have to press control and
option I believe to search on but
actually I didn't know that you can also
use the caps lock key itself as your
voiceover key so you know just we
remember that you you can press let's
say caps lock + key or you can press
control + option + K so both are
equivalent so since now I we know that
we can use the caps lock key then that's
probably easier to use in pretty much
every situation
yeah so one thing that is yeah and the
reason you use this keyboard help that
you can activate by although it was all
commands presses a key the corner this
works out
yup teachers
is the is the current screen reader
that's playing is it a bit too fast
control shift our cursor and how about
your own on your own computer it's 512
percent volume 100% initiative boys I'll
come back is a 50 percent 25 percent 26
growth this was 31 percent maybe I think
does this people at all for you want try
get know as I'm just trying
hey OH
takes account as well close Dixon can
add the vertical lines winter button
okay window toolbar so anymore this PC
the old on down giraffe so the the the
way that you know about help works is
that when you activate it by pressing
voiceover plus K is basically it
basically tells you over GG sorry it in
B city allows you to it sort of a safe
sandbox for you to experiment with
pressing various keys on your keyboard
so for example control okay so just
bored out studying currently we're
conscious if you enjoy what area
question okay so if you were to give me
a second
I'm sure wise not speaking oh no visible
table to interact voiceover chichi
welcome okay see how the press right so
if you depress if you if so it tells you
the keys of function when you press a
particular keystroke so for example if I
pressed voiceover plus F control I also
control every tax within the window so
all these are it's basically a safe soft
sandbox for you to play with different
commands and so that you know what these
commands do control meaning and the
hotel cold means that like the concept
to the beach party on the beach you know
unique one floaties and we have one fire
if it's not raining at 5:30 you're gonna
still meet on the beach we have some
drones and we still want to pretend
right control then you're gonna move on
to level five stops early and gets the
whole glass room it's almost as good as
being at the beach and we're gonna set
up the party in the dinner they're great
it's gonna be a lot of food and drinks
and a lot of DBS so anywhere see you
later thank you
I fired what's the time now 5 5 what 5
no no I said no she didn't okay
step one of also anything else no that's
not enough right this mess okay starting
keyboard hell right so you know if
you're ever not sure on which key to
press and then you know just just use
this if I helped to do experiment and so
the other soft thing that is some it
might be helpful for you guys to
configure Safari a source data on the
help sheet right at the top
no tab search around your website so now
has all kinds like suit surgeon
vegetarian so one thing is like you know
that our young order he did to was that
there are multiple screen readers are
available so since Windows is sort of
the most like populist platform there
are currently two actually three major
ones but the way that Windows screen
readers work and Mac three meters well
are substantially pretty different so
you know peaceful I'm you know not so
like I'm some not as some familiar you
know we've met you know so please bear
with me a bit on that so here the the
website that we want to go to to for
this particular demo so what what we're
gonna do is to look to see if we can
look for information on a particular a
particularly popular book by going to
book repository so if you open a new tab
on safari your focus should be should be
on the address bar and you should be
able to start typing okay hey-oh
and then and then you can just and this
is the and this is the site for book
repository this book depository sees
everyone able to you know hear what's
here or something that roughly matches
what you heard just down or is anyone
having sharing something different
okay so here so here on this web page
there are some ways that you can
actually navigate to the you know try to
the next heading to the previous heading
to the next list and so forth at least
but in the bottom of the of the document
but there but voiceover I guess in a
vision you know update they create a
more you know finger efficient way of
moving so what you can do is that you on
this page you can you can press the left
and right arrows to together to toggle
on to to um you can press it to toggle
quick quick nap on and what this allows
you to do is that you can move around
this page by pressing the left arrow
keys yeah so press control option shift
and down arrow
if you don't appear to be able to
actually move anywhere inside inside
this content please stop us yeah right
so now that the sort of though so this
is of one difference the way voice of
dustings what it does is that in sort of
groups logically logically distinct
items to together and then what it
allows you to do is to efficiently get
for an overview of the main video window
without having to tab through every
single link on the webpage so for
example if I stop interacting with this
particular web content if I if I were to
press the left over arrow keys I'm now
on this particular part of Safari and
this is the real head button and so
forth so this if you lets you explore
the interface without necessarily being
bogged down by details which is why you
need to so-called interact or zoom into
or set your particular focus on to this
web content right so now I'm interacting
with this web content so to move to the
beginning of the pitch you were pressing
over server plus home and voiceover plus
end okay
is there hope no one is it function with
its no okay I forgot the key sorry my
house it's okay it's donkey okay
and so what you can do now is that when
you switch is that you can press left or
right arrows to visit clean house
oops oh my Khan house so yeah it's over
appears that are there isn't homes home
there isn't a home key on soft your
screen is breaking those piercings oh oh
okay function function is the very end
here is andreas woman thanks yep so what
was all can you just an auskey home so
when you when you mentioned a home key
on Mac its function left and then and
this function right so for if you want
to modify with a voiceover modifier in
total it caps lock function left for
home capsule function and for right Oh
hmm
so if I were to press caps lock function
and and I met but so yeah so this works
contact so so that means that the first
item on this peak is a PC contact is a
contact link and si and as I use as I
use the left and right arrow keys to
move I'm soft moving through different I
elements of this page click information
source link rocket leg truck link heart
situation so another way of navigating
let's say that you want to define a
specific thing is to use something
called the voice of rota that you can
turn on using voiceover plus you and
what this brings up you can think of
this as a two-dimensional
menu where you can press up and down to
basically move true sorry so what what
you can do is that you can press the
left or right arrow keys to move to up
to select a particular type of web
element that you wish to move by so it's
either come control option you are just
are caps lock + you to activate this
voiceover / rotor so you can just you
know use the left and right arrow keys
and up and down to explore this voice
while rotor and what you can do is that
the other thing you can do is that let's
say that you know that you you know you
you know filter display so you can
basically just start to type and over
here myself I've narrowed it down to
three things and over here if I were to
press ENTER then you actually be taken
to the to the link or the kind of
element that you chose so what you can
do is also so these are one way of also
navigating this page and so if you look
at these headings if you can if you find
this you know a list of headings there
are lots of headings on this page so
just by just by looking at this list are
you can actually gain some sense of how
this page is structured so in the
heading level one is the main is where
the main content starts followed by the
this best-ever book lists popular
reading books and so forth so this is
one way that you can navigate by using
the route and you can escape by pressing
the escape so the other so an adult of
thing that you guys can try is um
besides using this rotor
you can also arms off press the
up arrow and right arrow keys to
together and what this does is that
sorry
controls it allows you to choose again
allows you to choose what type of
element you wish to move by so you can
press up arrow and right arrow or up
arrow and left arrow to sort of cycle
through this list and then what and then
what you can do is let's say marks that
I am words without fast legs
hey so let's say that I press you know
up and right repeatedly until I'm
heading so oh yeah this only works so I
can press up and down to actually move
by that particular elements type so so
now my second was a headings so this is
another way of navigating around by
using the this by using dr up and left
or right arrow keys to select by the
kind of element that you want to move by
and then using up and down to - to move
to the next or previous of occurrence so
this is so so so far I've shown you two
ways of navigating and then there's
another way that you can also navigate
by activating some something called
single letter quick navigation mode
which you so for this to work you need
your your original quick navigation mode
we on by pressing left and right okay
it's on now so what what I can do now is
to press our voiceover + oops sorry
voiceover plus our cue whoops where's
the cue yes cute
what's work
yes we really do it hey maybe quickness
as we all know it's hard on contraption
I'll just press Q on its own mm-hmm
sorry it seems to be difficulties second
blank releases you looked for holidays I
saw that a B this was about Q - check
check
Thanks voiceover GG whatever content you
are currently on wait some me oh D oh
yeah yeah you worked on my machine
just try to think which question about
which version of maybe I can just get
this yeah okay maybe I might just if you
guys come on
if you guys are also helping yeah thanks
if voiceover plus Q doesn't seem to be
doing anything oh no it up me well
you're in keep our help just yeah I was
in just now
then can you turn quick nap on starting
he would have control Q oh this is
control Q so this is some it's also kept
option control option q yes okay sobbing
G good smoke
turn off almost a bomb single that
equipment even water to turn on single
letter quick navigation whoa it's okay
if it that's all it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay
so maybe this feature might have been it
could have been you know introduced in a
or you know you know different version
of voiceover or mic so when I when I
tested it only but when I when I tested
it it worked for me but it but perhaps
it requires some up some existing update
oh it doesn't worry
yeah yeah okay so yes it uh or is
overcome when you six items you're
currently in a voiceover closing
voiceover he'll menu having a level two
favorite others so another useful sort
of command you can try is also bringing
a voice voice of our our help and in
this menu it sort of this is way where
you can self get helped online
controller commands to draw action a
change to fall for various voice over V
V resources or not control option K
commands help control option HH and help
many fourteen items you are currently in
a voice 140 so over here in this in
Venice in the command menu you can start
typing to basically filter for to look
for a specific command so this is useful
if you forgot the keystroke for a
particular command and you wanted to use
it anyway
so let's say I wanted to activate this
fine previous landmark oh man
heading level one link okay how's Atari
calm you are her in the other heading
month
yeah right so the next thing that I
would like to sort of demonstrate now is
to is to move is to move to the nearest
farm field so let me see the command for
this is all its give me a second
enter search times
is such fun are getting such boys over
chichi quick second and this aside and
research times creating such long furry
owners now padding in the whole three
elements navigation without single key
quick nap information so this is so vo
be using that work even without single
key wouldn't have to go one column on
action-comedy keystroke Corral two
column one move to next item regardless
of level comma to the old press command
+ H so so this is this table will be the
set of commands that view will be using
so you can go to the next hitting by
pressing voiceover fast
c'mon class voiceover plus command plus
each and if you add shift to the
previous keystroke that should allow you
to move the previous that should allow
you to move them to the previous element
and you can also do a voiceover plus
command + X Oh
okay so in this case that moves you to
the next or previous list but in this
case this page has no lists and the
corresponding graph the corresponding
excuse me
the so you can stop experiment with this
so on voiceover plus command it sort of
the common keystroke followed by various
are letters on the keyboard that allow
you to move to various various things or
is a virtual chip or is emergency oil
content were currently on right
ah Oh sister single-vehicle mangy ong
he's very intelligent if thanks thanks
thanks thanks inside welcome all right
so to move to the next or the previous
you know form here you will do no more
now with not happy
what doesn't seem to work voice Alex on
there go to the next one it's poised
over come on Kate
come on oh yeah hmm wait why is it not
reading
now reading he made me stop stop
most did pick a die yeah I think my
hardest use my own okay sound output
devices table Safari the blank textbooks
and we're currently Auto laid inside of
web content to click this link press
control option space to exit this wet
area press kinks so you want to go to
menu
you found the Harare clear email address
edit dollars with search love search
looks like slash slash slash choice and
speak a search text restore what is it
no voiceover kept stop come on Ethan
command is here next would've yeah
thanks search button yep you are
currently on a button to click search to
mom + G to move to the next or previous
few and then here I assume any sort of
instructions as voiceover will tell you
you can start to type in this field
hey so let's see data I want to search
for this particular book F I oh yeah
fires space hey n D and you are why Yuri
and in our link I'm in a press link post
link envelope contact and then I press
ENTER to - voiceover help menu six items
link envelope contact us heading level
two filter of your search heading level
two filter by categories heading level
one search results for fire in fury you
are currently on it so I I press ENTER
to submit the search result and then I
used heading navigation to move to the
mean such area showing one two three
zero of nine four results most popular
pop up one clickable link to you are
click link for link right pointing
double arrow link to six percent while
fire and fury
adding level three link fire and fury
you are currently on a heading level
three so this is the first
result and we can sort of just be like
what's next
what sort of beneath this heading blank
Michael Wolfe black outline black star
it works so over here it actually said
outline black star
so it's not able to tell you how many
stars are we how many stars this
particular book has so I guess it's I
guess at this um because it's sort of
the soft isn't a label for this so it
doesn't translate 0-5 gentoos euro 1/8
so that's and so that's it I'm not
insane
fire it fear in this particular book and
then I can just press I can just
activate this particular link link hours
blank envelope contact and now I am here
on the on the details for this
particular book heading level one fire
and fury heading level two product
details you are currently heading level
one fire and fury and then from here you
can return the plane we carry points use
the arrow keys to explore this page
connected via parities link by link
share link envelope link that link T
link so over here if you are cooling if
you were to arrow right a few times from
from the heading you were he not notice
it saying blank F F worklink
t.t worklink P P and so forth so I start
I suspect this is because the link isn't
currently label but I guess it is the
distance for Facebook Twitter the first
time and this is the restriction
outrages of the book and then and then
now if we move to the next heading
heading level 2 product details you are
a current through the product details
view and then we can form get more
paperback vertical line three three six
pages you are a cup dimensions one five
three X and then we can get more
information on this book yeah
so you know like try to see if if you
guys are able to hear something similar
mmm publication date 0 5 10 to 0 1 8 you
are currently
does anybody have some difficulties or
questions up to up to this point Jesus
because different laptops I've imagined
Windows laptop surgery how do you
overcome that do you have like yes so
this is so pop why I also have it harder
for me to conduct this portion of the
bookshop because when I was doing sort
of the preparation and testing I was
doing it so on a windows keyboard deal
so the hero here on the Mac is very
different so I kept on trying to I kept
on trying to perform home antonin even
work initially let's see why do business
laptop so how do you example the whole
keyboard almost cease only a few those
function keys and so forth yeah so what
we do is that probably have to you know
consult the menu or whatever of the
manufacturer and then excuse me and then
I'm sick and then see if that you know
we can figure out C on it inside of
content she likes it sorry and then see
them and then see if we can rescue it's
okay and then see if we can figure out
how this works the other sort of thing
that I've usually tries to turn on the
equivalent of the keyboard help mode and
impress various key combinations and see
why it says use that your fingers always
stuff yeah so I guess it's similar to
like touch typing so whether you don't
BAM usually type you don't look down
onto the keyboard like once you are used
together yeah mmm
yeah so if you guys are like comfortable
or okay with like so far looking at this
particular website the answer of the
next challenge for you guys would be to
get specific pieces of information of
amazon.com for another product right you
want to know how to dance we can cut
that one just starting out sorry tight
jeans to hear that yeah so the next one
we're gonna do is because Book
Depository is definitely more in a sense
of all that amazon.com and is on the
horse as well is very good so everyone
can use video screen to Thomas
come on I'll go to jail for the witness
70% said 70% control control control
control control caps-lock FFN control
and fine
[Music]
you have to realize
Oh Stella
when you have the most I think you
process
so challenge or try to get some pieces
of information of the same book on
amazon.com so the books think this case
is why I hope you eat and so some I mean
subpoena that I can give you guys you
know that there is a command to move the
mix of figures for you you can also move
the mix of command T these will be the
most useful commands for you and you
call you when you call you
Serg rancher website name and attest has
alternate items blank di d r i.e return
Janusz if your computer no sir
I've initiated a touch touch touch to
help she does it help okay sure
file / / / user / cristoeosenhorblog
okay yeah so any issue you face just
reason I had to come over we'll try our
ship together view
so so because because on the Google
slides right I put the information ready
to entry
oh my god can you log on to here guys
yeah no just use Bella's computer I just
talking to y'all
I can't even possibly some characters
she is too heavy oh all right so the on
your can you edit your cheat sheet
nobody I'm not ready no difficulty we
were trying why don't you use mr.
computer let me just open notes control
space
the media is my token daughter because
we want to put the information into
extract
command space option command f5 command
f5 or command and that's mesquite
snubbing keyboard help voiceover off
yeah
hmm
keeping reais be a number anymore first
you're starting tomorrow using Kindle
eBook press look I think this drink
you can roam around so if anyone
anything that you can help them
so it cuz XPS the body
they said
Oh
for what what butane
you
Oh
No
[Music]
using we can do is
yeah
Oh
oh yeah disco monkey you're an F for the
voice-over on safari voiceover teaching
window price because yeah so duck the
kendo price right it's a bit of a trick
question because the we because the
reader Amazon does it fish is also not
perfect you know I heard someone talking
about how the it's a bit confusing so
what happens is that the way that
Amazon's page is structured the heavy
heading level one that describes the
books you know it's the name of the
result of the name of the product but
then the place that they put the window
price might actually be before that so
that might happen sometimes so that's
the you know that's - it's a bit
confusing downloads button you are
currently at file / / / user / Christy
TPS : / lefty
scoping location each so now I'm gonna
just try this experiment to go to Amazon
Hey Amazon amazon.com bookmark image
Timisoara amazon.com bookmarks so here
it actually um tomi amazon.com when only
typed in and so this is its autocomplete
suggestions support looking in : / / WWE
Amazon eBay
yep so this Amazon's amazon.com and this
is Emma's all so now I'm gonna do some
wolf in and they love loaded sorry um
turn xform field last uploaded last
frame amazon.com online shopping for
electronics apparel can blow a balloon
at you you are currently on menu to
choose this menu item press until
uploaded amazon.com online Chung's for
electronics apparel computers
Hey voiceover off voiceover on Safari
amazon.com all departments surgeon Papa
button so it select the department from
from venya on Amazon speech when you
press voiceover + command + J then you
can actually usually be on this box and
then if you and then when you're on this
box you can start typing search text
field blank you are currently on a text
field to enter text in this field type
so is so thus is anyone you know not on
this particular on this particular view
in the weapon yeah so just F I you are e
hey M D and F you are
why fury so I'm just type and I've just
pressed and thought and I'm now waiting
just waiting for the page to industrial
in scientific degrees
oh yeah okay Mike I three is off sorry
let me just repeat is again open
location selection amaz okay PepsiCo and
month unless you don't wanna believe
Amazon n0n calm web console with 87% a
percent loaded 88 89 percent in love
look all departments searchin pull
uploaded all do banner one item link
love love all departments searchin Papa
button appliances you are currently
uploaded all departments searchin Papa
button select the department search text
field look at the my fury yeah
all departments searching papa button
search six items books kindle store
politic and then not gonna move by today
heading level one search results we're
currently on Hanna you can press a voice
of ups kebab Plus each to move you to
the next hitting and so now I'm in a
surface also I'm gonna see if the
results also hitting's as well fire and
fury inside the Trump Whitehouse link
fire and fear and yeah so I'm laying
layups in 90 percent 90 percent 90
percent loaded 90 percent loaded you are
currently on a link right so you told me
that the PK is almost done and I will
try to move to the first to the first
Stanner one item okay it's done to the
first hitting again palm loaded Safari
menu navigation global navigation one
item 55 86 to 87 burning up 1890 percent
90 percent 90 percent 90 percent 90
percent 90 percent 90 percent 90 percent
loaded not 90 percent loaded so it's
okay when it's done it is actually um
place this discrete like chop sound -
basically yeah this - to tell you when
the page has finished loading for real
and then I can also vote by hitting
again print in dialogue link 50 76% 889
for 89 percent loaded
have you entered the web content
oh yeah yeah so this is my thing about
this thing to link Amazon navigation
setting items you are currently on a
link padding level five to items by new
one $7.99 you are during the yellow 5 I
am on so the first hitting the iPhone
will first heading heading level 5 to
items by new one $7.99 walls by new and
it is KZ cost $17 and a blank pinch
blank Twitter lame Pinterest heading
level five times by new once quantity
one quonset list price trick save one in
stock ships from insult by amazon.com
yeah Add to Cart button depending level
five link turn on one click ordering for
this browser you are currently on a
heading level five heading level five
other sellers on Amazon a heading level
one three items fire and fury inside the
Trump White House hardcover January 5 so
the way that the result is a key
structure is a bit funny because you
have information about the price and
shipping options before the actual title
as well as the author of the book so
this little puppy funnily on this page
by blank Michael Wolfe link so I can you
order early online to continue to move
sequentially to the right author link
link 3 Clank Amazon charts not
horizontal separator seolin formats in
the kindle wonder blank rep Kindle one
$1.00 in six four cents button and it is
the price on you are currently on a
button link par cover once entered
loaded link eight-foot linked paperback
link link to seven new from one G
dollars in slink
one collectible for your friend read
more clickable frame you are currently
on a frame to enter the web area press
control option shift down arrow read
more click horizontal separate link ref
equals M underlined link underlying one
and this is software currently on this
ref equals something is an example of
hitting with a strange label and I can
continue the move heading level two
frequently brought together heading
level 2 customers who bought this item o
spatting level 2 two items sponsored
products with left heading level
to special offers in heading level two
editorial reviews heading level three
review heading level three about the
author heading level two product details
and this is economy on heading level two
so actually the winner this is leader is
also not perfect because the product
details which is you know is is right
here at the bottom car cover three three
six pages and this is the no of pages
are currently on attacks on cover
publisher Henry Holt incompetent
language English ISBN 1 0 the isbn-13
970 once you fire zero one five eight
zero six two this is your current
isbn-13
and then if I just continue to move down
a few more times heading level two more
about the pending novel three three
items heading level two two items
sponsored product heading level two
customer reviews heading level three top
customer reviews you are a current link
smooth slow go clink 5.0 out of five
stars so this is like zero out of five
link reading this book is like January 5
so this is the you know so this is the
information for the top customer review
so like you know hopefully like the way
that I sort of did like most of that was
by using hitting navigation by using
voiceover + command + H to move to the
next hitting and voiceover + Tramonto
Shift + H to move to the previous
heading and then using the left arrow or
right arrow key stroke moves you with
using sequentially from your current
position as well as using voiceover +
command + G to move to the next or
previous form view so this soft
particular keystroke keeps on tripping
me up because J isn't really it isn't
intuitively intuitively assigned yeah
son of a giveaway button page one
okay Becky yeah
loaded loaded thank you so much yeah
yeah yeah no girls gonna do it segment
on hey get off because he's dead you
guys to smell sorry
yeah I think
notes safari voiceover off
didn't
yeah
what
so now we've been talking all about like
all the rules the compliance and that is
what we should strive it so after like
auditing a website then you find a box
and then you try to become plain so I'm
just gonna do a quick overview of what
it do what we're talking about so this
is think of web content accessibility
guidelines WCAG right now it's on 2.0
and then it's about how to make website
accessible in all ways so current so it
comprises of principles guidelines
success criteria and techniques so so
these guidelines are kind of governed by
four overarching principles so
perceivable operable understandable and
robust and then these under these four
principles are twelve guidelines so the
success criteria for these guidelines is
for a two double-a to triple-a so this
is just how you see how complying you
are these standards and each of them has
the techniques you can take so gonna go
into some ways of how you can achieve
these guidelines theta and it is also
like done and that's a lot of stuff
online but you can learn more about and
sort of us the first the first one is
perceivable so this is not just for
people like we have different types of
disabilities but also for web crawlers
robots so this is just like Dickson
mentioned like apps like instant paper
that actually depend on the ability to
pass a website in perceivable manner so
making sure your website is perceivable
in this way second is operable so the
user is able to use it that they can
achieve the intended function
that is to be understandable so this is
so this is just that you you can convey
the message of the website and that your
users don't feel like they're lost and
4/5 robust so it's a bother to keep
updated with latest like different
technologies for example SmartWatch if
you want like all these new technologies
and platforms coming up you need to make
sure that your website is robust to all
these new stand new technologies also
for different users so there are twelve
guidelines as you can see it's lumped
under different principles we'll just
focus on one for today so we don't
overwhelm you so and the first one the
most basic it's providing text
alternatives so this is not just for
images it's also for videos for graphs
like anything that is not text so in in
terms of HTML the practical meaning of
what you have to include it's like for
input fields you need to include a name
so let's say you have an input field for
just like writing your credit cut in but
then if you don't put in a name
attribute in your HTML tag there's no
way the screen it is gonna understand
what are you trying to ask the user
input in here and then for images you
should all give an alt text and because
like for example when Dixon was
navigating Book Depository he was going
to like the Home icon but they just ran
up home but I just read a house and then
like for similar things as well so for
icons for images you need alt text so
that the screen reader kind of stand
what is this image and quite the note is
that alt text should also be descriptive
so for example if you like just right
picture of a student it's not very
helpful and some someone who can see the
visual input you can get a lot of more
information or this picture than just
picture of a student so you can put some
small details like
engineering student working in
microscope lab and in another last
example is link text so a lot of times
on websites people will write describe
my link it's just like click this link
but you should be more descriptive also
like click this click to view this
article on web accessibility something
like that and now yeah it's gonna talk
about Aria so Aria it's one of the ways
you can achieve these guidelines and
it's a pretty fundamental for web
accessibility
generally using your laptop for this
[Music]
what do you need is yours and then I
ever read from mine that's my place
already connected anyway yeah I cannot
hear any sense on Rios
thank you
you can't hear your sound oh is it a
brutal thing okay so you can just reach
our son yeah yeah okay nice so now I
will talk about just give you a brief
introduction about area accessibility
ipi and as a and
like how how and why we have used this
and then this one will give you a
details like implementation how we used
area roles in attributes so at first I
will talk about excessively
accessibility API so what are
accessibility API is actually it is the
tours to give information to screen
reader for example you have a lot of
elements in your UIs so how can really
don't know what to reach out for the
user so they need the I try to provide
for example okay we have how many
elements in the unites have many images
and what what type of element we have
like images are label links or headers
so so that is why I mean it is so for
example on the website everybody know
that Dom tree right so down to the Dom
tree is one of those accessibility API
actually actually Dom tree itself it's
not the accessibility right but the
screen reader can make use of this and
it become API accessibility API
successfully please Yelling's so and now
what is the accessibility tree so
specifically on website we this are
applicable for website because
accessibility tree actually is the sub
subset of the dom tree system modified
downstream so they're different between
its and the dom tree is usually
accessibility is smaller than don't you
why because they it doesn't contain you
are decorating elements so for example
website we have a lemon feel and then we
have a deep fried and then I believe we
have a few elements like a few Spanish
just for decorating like we want to show
some icons that is for beautiful focus
sorry and we have some links and some
header inside this div so the Dom tree
contains all Beltane but for the
accessibility tree we only need links
the header and yeah that's all all the
space or the icons will be chopped outs
so it's only contest any necessary
information for screen readers so and I
forgot to mention one point that in in
enriched internet complication not on
website we need something to convert the
usual accessibility I tried to platform
specific accessibility as well
what is so what is and then I can ever
move on to area so what is area and area
is the tours that I'm innocent
before that used to map web
accessibility rights in the platform
Pacific today yeah
why are so area why we need to use area
we need this because uh at first is very
easy very easy to use and you only need
to add some absolutely they are acting
elements and second thing is is it
reduce coding I mean you don't need it
it doesn't add up
calling overhead it's mean you don't
need to like write a two-minute code you
don't need to build a separate module or
any complex thing for this and then it's
a quite effective case isn't you can you
can use you can improve accessibility of
your UI and without affecting your
current design for example you have one
icon for example you have an icon to the
soft at a button to make a phone call
so the icon is look like the telephone
no but you don't have any text on this
so if if you want to change yeah
you have many ways but I give you two
ways first is
this icon into the button with the text
for example coal or please press this
button to call anything else so this
will if you change like this your design
will change the second way is using use
areas so you only add one attribute to
this to tell screen reader that ok this
icon is a button and it is it its name
is called so the screen reader will read
out loud to the user that ok there is a
call button
but the design rules will stay the same
and the last thing is it is standardized
it is support by its fully support and
which have documentation as well so the
thought is I don't know how can you we
use okay I will move on to the next part
that's how we use area actually we use
area by adding attribute mostly by
having our wheel to your XML elements if
I show you injury so then and nice we
after adding this to do to help us we
need a recognized elements you should
divide your website into resume how
reagent and next you should we should
buying dynamic elements into some s SVD
events so that we can update any changes
from those dynamic element so listen
we'll talk more about this later
you specification but even though we
have area already I think we should use
the basic XML elements as much as
possible for example you have it the
simple website
I think basically marries enough for
example we put out text for images we
use button we use header I think this is
you know some simple ways we don't even
we even don't it as well
Aria loops it's the clamor so to build
we have two types of area attribute
usually we have area rose and area
attributes so what is area Rose rose it
attribute that will we help screen we
will help screen it and know that what
is the purpose of this element for
example if you put a roll equal to like
radio button or equal to but then for
example your icon your spans your DV or
whatever we become radio button become
actually when it's generated from dom
tree to accessibility three if we
convert this leaf or this span or
something out there that we come to
radio button for example so it will help
user know what is the purpose of your
icon well and how do second request is I
can't
all right so next is re attribute and we
actually build yourself at the thing to
to tell you the state and the properties
of the elements so for example again
radio button or check text box
alright so if you put our checks give
them to true if you show that it is
checked and another thing is we have
area hidden attributes really will help
you to hide this element to from from
screen readers so all most of the
attributes will be prefixed by area so
if you need further information you can
go to those references to define the
articles about area
okay thanks guys so now Dixon will
continue my hearts even or any questions
about you having a question area or WCAG
maybe I think us gang antics like
Singapore webs like website from
Singapore like how much of it is the
affiant is like complying to these hmm
maybe like less than half I mean yeah so
soft depends like just if the website is
that say a wordpress blog and using you
know your default theme so actually by
default I've either the saw the themes
actually have all these accessibility
started by default so it's you usually
only when the website has some what
wants to leave some let's say a button
or a checkbox tech she looks a bit
different to what you usually see so
that's so so sometimes instead of using
an actual checkbox
you know element and then using CSS to
start it but the do you say they just
use a div element and then visually they
make it look like a checkbox but as far
as your um is concerned is actually not
a checkbox so that's usually where it
happens
hmm
first those
oh sorry
do do la do la like this Aden is no yeah
so it's because you are by default it's
already no no this just the the core
elements are already by default method
access at 38 yeah all right I trusted 33
so you don't have to do anything special
it's only when you want to do like rich
applications so there's four areas like
you wanna do then you need to use Aria
landing a div to be the main part of
your web page article that info or a
banner and we also need Aria attributes
to set the state and properties on these
on your like a checkbox
so it's like it's it's funny when you
are thinking of creating that a custom
react component or customer or a custom
angular component so that's typically
when you would reach for using Aria
obvious or these types of opportunities
just like whenever you can talk the
recommendation is to use the built-in
like html5 or we do have a lots of the
energy goes for example this even now
and attribute unless audio or less video
great attack so that is you don't even
need flash player anymore to do some of
these things so this that we go
recommendation to use doing elements
when possible and only one is really not
then to reach for aria to succour thick
you know what by thing I mean you you
make the eleven of here as if it's it's
a normal HTML do int element so this so
like this off of what are we going
through so hopefully then the student
mix and hopefully the next section in
time will clarify a bit hmm
okay so on yes okay
we don't like
so in this sort of final section so you
know I would like to like explain about
how how you you guys can actually create
custom HTML like you know I mean custom
UI videos then when there's really no
other you know way of achieving of
achieving what your site requires so
this is this is the advice that I saw I
talked about we fee
just now he's basically used in HTML
whenever possible and you know
accordions are pretty popular so you
will see that later on but there's
actually now an html5 element to do this
right so also over here so this is the
landmarks that we touched on briefly so
maybe just let me just quickly like
devil's tree because we went to this we
eventually bit of this armoire go with
like really really fun so we this pitch
I can remove by landmarks so over here
from the top when I press the command to
move the next landmark so this is on
navigation you know lemma such lemma so
this way I can find such items the mean
they're not followed by another
navigation that map and this
complimentary are and this complimentary
sort of landmark is but it basically
means information that complements the
main part of the page but it also makes
sense then standalone as well and
content info means are means that this
is information that you find at the
bottom of the page so you can think of
it as if
so the width so the way that you
actually write a landmark is that you
why he say that latter then you enclosed
your menu bar in a day for example so
one possible way to make that landmark
we see less deep space raw equals quote
Neff unquote
so that basically gets translated to a
part of your web page with a navigation
landmark so so I'm doing this in sofa is
these are pure HTML solutions so when
doing this you the recommendation is to
ensure that every part of your web page
is within some lemma and so basically
what which lemma to pick is usually
quite intuitive and because you know you
were used there for your Lobby for your
navigation bar and so forth but the
preferred solution is again to use built
in html5 elements over here some html5
elements already have implicit rules as
you can see from this table so you know
I highly recommend using these whenever
whenever you you whenever possible so
next is you know implementing a custom
button so if you really need to do this
sort of the way that you implement this
so like insert in the in Alex use of
sections what I want to show you guys is
on how to how sort of all of these
custom vision should sound so that when
you guys are implementing these things
you know what what do
but nine two minutes maybe you that's
right
f5 in the next two minutes or so say
what the party needs two minutes
Oh Rafa yeah coz Phi 3d Oh
so over here this so this is soft
roughly how a button Ranma or it can
sound like so this is a vintage button
so it actually said finish button and as
far as I am aware of just by listening
to this is a regular button so if I were
to activate this button it actually it
actually prints as you expect but the
WIDA is actually implemented is usually
using a custom set your so on your diff
that you will have for this button you
basically said roll equals to button and
then let's say that your button has
multiple possible states for example so
this is a mute button and it said mute
button toggle not pressed so the way the
reason it in those days
it's because it has n area - pressed
equals to true or false a trivial attach
to it and when I press ENTER on this
pressed so I know that this button is on
act is active so the way that you do
this is just using this is this is v1 a
thickness now so the the our next thing
is implementing two tips
so in this right so I'm on this username
I'm near this you user you feel so what
I'm going to do is I'm just gonna press
the tab key to bring my my focus here
and it's it also known as user ID
so this is the text of the to tip
annually and he was able to
automatically read it out and the winner
it's implemented is basically by there
is a diff right next to this arm edit
box that is initially set to be hidden
when the page loads and when your car
when this thing with is focused their
scripting them reacts to this event and
then is basically unhides the two team
but then the next question you might be
wondering sir how does the screen reader
know that you know that to tip is
related to this box so the defense has
this row equals to this row over here so
the input trough box actually has this
and then after this is the corresponding
HTML the input IRA - described by it
equals to something and this basically
means that this element has some
additional description that lives
somewhere else
and we refer to this element by its ID
so this is how it knows about how to
read the routine and then after that the
Softee if I know like thing to note is
that for two tips to work properly you
should not only the Sun for onmouseover
events but you should also be listening
to the on focus event because the on
focus is sort of more device agnostic
and I believe that also works for
touchscreen devices as well and
correspondingly
yeah yeah sorry I swear they were
showing us like sushi last night
oh yes yeah but it's actually what you
just arm so we gonna do - see ya soft
running a bit soft on Oh times oh but
over here I'll just vvp describe this so
this is just a non accordion so um this
is so an accordion it was something that
you do see fairly frequently and over
here what is that button like
unavailable expanded personal
information so the fact that it's
expanded its also due to the same reason
as before it said sorry as a similar
reason SN R er - expanded equals to drop
falls attached to this and next when I
have my focus on this element when I
press down the down arrow key its it
billing address button collapses now I'm
here and I know that this off header is
collapsed and I can press ENTER to
visibly open it up yeah and then I can
sort of V V what's under here so this
what what I mean by accordion so
basically the trick the trick to
implementing the accordion is just to
descend to the appropriate keyboard
events to make sure that when visually
you high you know the section you also
say that you know that this is
they collapse to BCC area - expandables
Falls yeah so that's the trick to doing
this sometimes hump okay custom which
isn't too long okay so guys I think we
are also cognizant of the time we are
slightly riding over D there there are
two more custom widgets to go true I
think we won't go to them now but we
quite self-explanatory we were shared a
slice of you and then you can look
through those so I think we will just
wrap up today if if you could just help
us with two things I think the first one
is potato photographer just left the
room but when he comes back if you can
take a photo together and then a second
one is if you can give us some feedback
if we can give you some feedback I just
go to this Facebook page just give us a
minute just okay this is because
yeah so if you could just go to this
Facebook page these abilities how much
like the page and then the there is a
link to a feedback form that you know we
really appreciate you could have us fill
out so that we can know what we can do
to improve the next time around so it's
an edible form this one the the healthy
perform so yeah if you could just have
us do that before you leave as well and
then when the photographer comes back we
can take a picture you can all get to
the beach this is a big deal
sorry is it when is the ring is
e-reading ready oh oh no
so once you fill up the once you fill up
the form you can leave your email and
then we will send you the slides from
there yeah I think there's a new feel
just double-check
guys so wait you feel up the feedback
form sorry my my bad I forgot to put in
a few for you to put your email address
so for the last question just type your
email day they will contact you from
this yeah